un père vesti que plus mastoc l'envers
le plus pervers qui ne fait pas bon
tomber entre les griffes des deux
impairs de descente de police la victime
cette semaine c'est michel boujenah
hommes de café théâtre comédia on peut
le voir actuellement dans le film trois
hommes dos à koufa et il sera du 4 au 10
décembre prochain
elle tient beaucoup
c'est nul on sent tout le monde
on y va
on
je sais pas
comme ça alors google alors c'est quoi
ton voile en asie accouche boujenah ses
vols bush cela ça c'est justement ça
bouge mais un bo le chien nov c'est bien
de quelle province de france à de tunis
elle a le temps de quelques années que
c'est plus français alors français mais
ça vous emmerde
ouais ça nous emmerde c'est qu'on était
français des bons français
je suis français d'accord sur scène
choisissent alors j'ai fini là car de
cheseaux j'ai peur j'ai un beau sport
d'un passeport français et ça vous
endormir d'un soldat double nationalité
c'est ça j'ai dit non c'est non arabes
c'est pas une nationalité
ah bon c'est quoi le nom à prendre c'est
quoi la prends nous allez vas-y arabe
c'est une religion alors bien sûr
religion ces arabes d'accord tu
t'appelles bouger alors un prêtre et
prénom c'est quoi
michel et de votre talent à d'autres des
frais non non j'ai que michel sur des
tablettes apprend que michel tessier
décret et non j'ai que michel c'est la
religion c'est quoi la religion si juifs
voilà c'est bien précis soit désirable
que tu nous racontes vous n'a jamais dit
j'étais agacé vous pardon ouais quoi tes
parents sont juifs tunisiens
mes parents ma mère mon père est juste
une dixième mais les juifs algérienne
c'est pour mieux vrai d'accord sa date
de naissance à 3 11 52 ça fait quoi ça
sert de 32 ans
si j'attends que vous comptiez on est
dans la merde mais tu as raison son lieu
de naissance
c'est tunis tunis en tunisie et c'était
français en 52 encore c'était france non
oui bien sûr c'était français donc été
français au départ mais non parce que
les nous on était tunisien on n'était
pas aussi compliqué mais c'est compliqué
commencez la robe bien français mais là
on est dans un pays français après tu
étais plus français mal en terre devenue
française voilà c'est ça en gros c'est
bon quand ça veut pas ça va deux
passeports un peu comme alger - lysiens
arabe juif et français
voilà c'est ça en gros et alain les
pellicules
oui beaucoup c'est un problème a les
cheveux gras avec le raec c'est une
pellicule une grosse panique une sèche
et les yeux étaient mieux pour est-il
maintenant je suis ni oui aux pièces
images photophone photophone tu vas nous
expliquer ce que c'est faux c'est
supporte pas la lumière
et bien alors quelle couleur des yeux
bleus blaise alibeu quand même un bleu
blanc rouge et la mer
en blouse bleue signal d'achat spa sa
circoncision qu'agente a fait ça très
très je sais plus mais c'est tout de
suite après la naissance de 10 ans 15
ans ouais non mais non je suis fatigué
surtout éléments c'est au bout de trois
semaines même pas quinze jours de la
naissance
donc c'est la salle opérations de thé eu
beau
il savait ça ouais des oueds et tout est
vraiment et ça qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une berry france parce que ces jeux
pour une périphrase et arles c'est dans
cinq usines à mal ces cantons dredi avec
une autre phrase de la même chose que
dans l'autre bonsergent qu'est ce que
c'est que la gérontophilie par exemple
la gérontophilie c'est pour les vieux un
syllogisme c'est quoi c'est le dire
aussi la même chose
non le syllogisme c'est par exemple
n'ont par exemple que les mecs qui ont
des impairs ouais c'est des cons vous en
portez vous êtes vraiment de coincer
sassi logistique la manutention à coups
de poing dans la gueule et l'armée tu
l'as fait avec moshe daianu yasser
arafat
j'ai pas fait l'armée t'as pas fait
l'armée et les pétitions que j'en fasse
non tu des latéraux normalement je
enfants en tunisie au maroc pour
l'enfance en francs mais je suis juste
et français visée français ce qu'on sait
que toi je te merde et alors mais t'as
pas fait l'armée mais parce qu'il était
question que je fasse l'armée enfin
c'est pourquoi les bases et j'ai pas
envie de faire l'armée mais parce que tu
que tu me vois moi avec un fusil oui ça
compliqué n'a pas de rôle d'audrey
d'environ 2 qui de l'armée est trop
grand passé mais non je fais réformer gt
mais non je conseille à quoi bg dit j'ai
dit oui
on veut enlever on veut on est là pour
ça va y aller à couches vous savez vous
avez de la chance que je sois blessé
mais que sinon génial je te jure toi tu
peux passer un mauvais quart d'heure est
d'accord c'est nous contre ce jugement
va se méfier maintien alors vas-y parle
pourquoi tu as fait d'armé l'armée g
j'ai pas vraiment parce que je leur dis
que j'avais du travail comme acteur et
que sinon crif foot est alarmé gimeux
juste rechange en sortant ils faisaient
foot ma carrière alors ils tant cru
ouais c'était pas vrai c'était pas vrai
nom et a menti à l'armée française est
un bagarreur j'aime pas le jeu j'aime
pas j'aime pas vraiment français ses
parents disent donc ça tu le dis pas
j'aime les femmes mais c'est pas un vice
nas est pas vraiment un lit ce n'est
qu'à quelques étagères produite et c'est
un truc que vous connaissez pas sarko
n'est pas avant tu fais mal alors je fus
maintenant allons-y
les cigarettes à un problème sourit je
m'arrête qu'est ce que tu vois des cia
américaine qu'elle marque combien
combien de cigarettes oui deux mille
paquets par jour dé quoi de mal bouffe
pas voulu tirer la fumée ah oui j'avais
à l'affût et rami c'est tout mais à huy
pas plus je peux pas fumer plus devant
les pétards ton film comme un large émoi
non les pétards genre et fumer quand
quinze ans ça t'a fait les rues non non
j'ai pas honte de le dire ça mais
l'arrivée de fumée des pédiatres en
satin cléry avec senna villarreal et ça
te fait rêver ça te fait quoi
ces places et je suis bien tel droit de
vote
oui enfin c'est plutôt socialiste
pendant ce communiste quand même je dis
non je suis pas socialiste ont remis
j'ai voté à gauche et je préfère voter
pour un con de gauche que pour un con de
droite
da c'est tout et waco mitterrand ça
comment leur de gauche c'est pas ça ils
sont écoutés jeu sa valeur de politique
d'avoir des mois je sais pas faire de
dragon age origins the non mais non
comme moi tu vois je ne parle pas de ça
et bien des fois je ne vote pas je
voudrais plus d'idées mon mimi et tes
beaux yeux là c'est à dire à pas mal de
propositions de paix des non mais
arrêtez avec vos questions
j'ai eu envie d'avoir envie de répondre
je vais te montrer moi
je répondrais je remettrai way et quand
tu baises tu éteins la lumière pas
toujours pas toujours tu passes il était
sur la table de la cuisine ou dans la
salle d'eau mais ya pas de règles là non
plus il n'ya pas de rallonger rebond ce
tube est pas les flics ont leurs règles
tous les règnes fiq a ses règles
vous avez vraiment envie de ça va passer
vraiment à la télé ça va vraiment la fin
parmi les gestes efficaces je trouve qu
une fin mais je trouve que le sens d'une
femme ce n'est pas sale ah ben non
donc dû base des filles qu'on est en
règle mais vous savez bien revendre
oui mais ça m'est arrivé et sa femme que
j'aime quand je me devoir arrêter à rien
parce qu'israël vient d'elle rien rien
allez vas-y take out dans la sa demi
volée beamish à sonoma coal analyses et
des filles au lycée intérim a enfin une
bonne réponse et quel effet cet aspect
je vous le dis elle pense était brûlée
elle quel effet ça leur a fait je vous
le dirai pas
si gay est ce que ces questions n'ayant
pas y résister pour lui faire plaisir
pour te faire plaisir d'annoncer est
chaud me l'a demandé
c'est marc levy que thuram a demandé
c'est avec se vendent pas bander non
mais ça m'est arrivé oui j'ai pas honte
de le dire mais combien payez sais pas
il n'y a pas de règle là non plus mais
là non plus sa taille avec dans l'aride
rail band assez dégueu l'influencé
d'alcool et combien pas ben ben j mais
je sais pas ça m'est arrivé
et qu'est ce tu fais dans ce cas là tu
rigoles la première fois que ça m'est
arrivé j'étais vraiment mal parce
j'avais honte
ouais et la deuxième fois tout est lisse
et comme la première cabine ont laissé
certaines options non voyant là et ça va
et ça m'a moins gênés me j'ai arrêté de
me culpabiliser à ckoi visite avec des
films dont tube rompre avec une paix
comme ça qu'est ce que tu fais tu lui
dis je suis désolé camarade tu bandes
par exemple la renaissance te fait rien
finalement
wendy dont michelin qui c'est au lecteur
préféré au cinéma charlie chaplin dakar
en parler mais qu'ils sont vivants et on
parle pas des cadavres dustin hoffman
destine à dieu depardieu oui
deux salles et la couche nicholson
nicholson et en france sont et 10 en
france j'aime beaucoup
cluzet je trouve que c'est un grand
acteur user du bien voilà sans exclusive
au conventionnement loubet sur france ô
et sur les films pornos ou à la france
va barder
pluzz et pas des moins connus la brute
le nouveau talent à bruz qu'elle a brûlé
notamment lambert chaussée avec flo rida
lambert et par le coni n'a j'aime
beaucoup même s'il est lech survivre
vincent lindon c'est un jeu c'est payant
et quand tu étais petit quel acteur tout
leur semble et miss charlie chaplin
avait dix ans et puis on s'est vus
docteur dit charlie chaplin qui t'aiment
pas là qui j'aime pas à temps qui j'aime
j'aime pas par exemple tout le cirque
sophie marceau fait place aux films à
savoir il va écrire un post à peu près
20 20 20 ou 25 millions 25 d'abord joué
pendant un an ce plan dit pendant deux
ans ce plan dit de suite et j'ai fait le
lien quoi ça 500 mille francs jouer dans
le champ jure je sais pas normalement
c'est pas c'est bien toi qui es en vie
ta feuille d'impôts qu'on demande c'est
marouani way est en tête de l'agencé tel
nous nous si les grands blast est amer
non mais c'est son boulot chacun
chantera t sur cette coupe un spectacle
c'est combien de temps d'une journée un
arbre ils sont obsédés salle louchart
pour une soirée c'est combien on bougera
pour une soirée c'est combien convient
peut inviter pour l'anniversaire de la
petite par exemple ça coûte combien tu
viens de faire le pitre à la maison fait
pour les anniversaires etc universal
j'ai jamais fait arrêter de faire les
années n'ont jamais fait ah bon j'ai
toujours joué au théâtre saint jean
d'août ayant un jour de personnes comme
étienne jamais liversay revue
je sais je sais pas mais c'est le choix
d'un homme resté pour moi avec par
présentation à peu près dix mille francs
anciens par représentation en france
non lui sembla une brique quoi awa bâ et
a peur du sida qui utilisent l aventure
on a les aventures mais non mais le si
beau c'est un drame au sida c'est un
homme bon qu'est ce que tu veux faire
oui c'est qu'est ce que tu veux tu peux
faire attention à comment je sais pas on
te demande comment tu fais attention
est-ce que tu mets des capotes se rendre
dans les rapports et les filles 1 est ce
que les américains ont des capotes
emmenons quel heureux que tu vas
attraper le sida alors l'ami déjà des
capotes il nous l'a dit tala dont une
fois dedans j'ai une folle capote dans
tv c'est oui une fois une fois du roi
d'écossé - avait apporté une capote
pourrais tu trouves ça grimpe aux
agressions nous limitent cette angoisse
il pose les questions en font pas là il
serait sûr ici on leur explique tout ce
que ça fait de mettre des capotes risque
fait plaisir ça fait mal mais ça arrive
du plaisir ça ait du plaisir
saleh du plaisir qu'ils préfèrent
attraper le sida que mettre des capotes
c'est ça non il sera exclu la seule
solution au portail sina ces nouvelles
égal qu'elle est dans la merde
clac c'est fini bravo et merci à michel
boujenah d'avoir joué le jeu et surtout
d'avoir survécu à cette descente de
police
une séquence qui aurait pu très basse à
+6 tapage nocturne
le retour des deux impairs à la semaine
prochaine et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu